let's take a look now at some of the  numbers for clark county commission  first off tonight commissioner michael  naft looks like he'll be holding on to  his seat over his challenger  michael thomas at 46 percent  commissioner marilyn kirkpatrick also  very likely at this point to be keeping  her hand on her seat in district b  as the chairwoman of the clark county  commission this has been the tightest  race we've seen over the last 24 hours  but at this point  stavros anthony our current las vegas  city councilman is leading district c  over ross miller but this is still  pretty close then assemblyman william  mccurdy looks like he's going to handily  take control over clark county  commission district d  brian